[Music]
we can have national voting and that
means get rid of the electoral college I
think that it's open to the discussion I
mean there's no question that the
popular vote has been diminished in
terms of making the final decision about
who's the president United States and we
need to deal with that would you support
getting rid of the electoral college
absolutely it's got to go I myself have
always been for lowering the voting age
to 16 I think it's really important to
capture kids when they're in high school
when they're interested in independence
of those who chose the first 10 just a
small glimpse of how radical
out-of-touch this new crop of 2020
Democrats have become all right joining
us now to talk about that much more is
the great one I call him he's the host
of life liberty Levin number one show
10:00 p.m. Sundays right here on Fox and
Levin TV you know mark you look at our
framers you go back to 1787 and this is
your this is your wheelhouse 16 year
olds to vote they want to stack the
Supreme Court with activist justices and
let's get rid of the electoral college
so New York and New Jersey and Illinois
in California will elect every president
going forward dying to get your reaction
and that and the new Green Deal
you know Sean this is one of the reasons
I oppose legalizing pot because
obviously we have a problem on Capitol
Hill look the greatest threat to our
Constitution and economic system isn't
any foreign power
it's the Democrat Party it's the leftist
within the Democrat Party because they
use our Liberty in our constitution to
destroy our Liberty in our Constitution
and they're very good at it look at this
you named some of them they want to
destroy the electoral college now what
would that mean why do we have an
electoral college we have an electoral
college and why do I have to explain
this to people who want to run for
president you knighted States because
there were
which had smaller populations that we're
not going to join the Union if the most
popular states were going to control the
entire country we have an electoral
college that keeps peace in this nation
we have a farm belt that's less
populated in urban areas we have an
energy sector that's less populated in
urban areas we don't want to be ruled by
New York City Los Angeles and Chicago we
should all have a have a role in this we
are Republic we are not a democracy
we're not a mob bakra see and what you
see here these aren't people running in
the Democrat Party they're running under
the mob party they want to get rid of
the electoral college well how do they
intend to a just think about this if
they want to get rid of the electoral
college you have to amend the
Constitution
you only need 13 states to say no you
think there's 13 states that will say no
I think there's 20 states that will say
no so they're absolute illiterates when
it comes to the Constitution they want
to pack the Supreme Court now we tried
this Franklin Roosevelt tried it you
know who stopped them his own vice
president and the Democrat Party they
want to pack the Supreme Court why
because they want to fix the outcome
they want to fix the outcome of
elections they want to fix the outcome
of court decisions this is very good
Banana Republic of the Democrat Party
they want to allow illegal aliens to
vote well why wait for them to come a
thousand miles into the United States
why don't we send absentee ballots to 7
billion people all over the world tell
me you don't need to struggle to get to
the United States you can just vote in
our elections they want to lower the
voting age to 16
why not lower it to 12 or 14 or 15 how
stupid is that I mean they raise the age
for booze they raise the age for
cigarettes to 21
you can't yet but at 16 you're gonna
help pick our president why are they
doing that because they indoctrinate all
these kids in high school and so forth
and they know how they're gonna vote
Democrat every decision they make or
everything they espouse is about power
controlling power do you think if we had
a million illegal immigrants coming
across the border and 75% of them one
day become United States citizens who
would vote Republican do you think they
would want to secure the southern border
you bet they would they'd have sniper
towers all over the place
they don't want Republicans coming into
this country the Second Amendment
now we have a knucklehead running for
president who says we should actually
start to confiscate weapons the First
Amendment they call this voter reform
where they want to take away free speech
now we're only three or four weeks into
this election and the kook's are in full
display what about our economy
nationalize energy nationalize energy
we're finally energy independent and
they want to destroy it
nationalize health care single-payer
wealth tax seventy to ninety percent
marginal tax the rate of that tax free
college guaranteed minimum income from
birth
guaranteed federal job three months of
taxpayer financed family leave expand
Social Security while the trustees say
it's bankrupt in 2034 that's the genius
Bernie Sanders by the way eliminate
existing border fences
that's bait oh-oh dork right there
eliminate ice reinstate the Iran nuclear
deal cut military funding and while
we're at it impeach the president indict
the President and date the president's
children and let's go ahead and impeach
associate Supreme Court justice
Cavanaugh that is quite a policy plan
that the Democrats have and we're only
three or four weeks into this mark if we
didn't forget one thing and I never like
to correct you because you always write
during birth and after birth abortion
right deliver the baby right make sure
the baby's comfortable then let the
mother decide Wow
did you ever think my luck in all your
years you would hear this
even be all these things you mentioned
ever no being seriously disgusted like a
hundred Democrats in Congress supporting
this and twenty twenty candidates listen
to how crazy these people are we're
gonna eliminate straws to save the
wealth but infanticide of human beings
is a right a choice between a mother and
a doctor no it's not I just want to say
one thing before we go to the president
United States thank you thank you for
being a statesman what you've done in
Israel will be remembered for a thousand
years the Golan Heights moving the
embassy from Jerusalem Tel Aviv to
Jerusalem taking on the terrorists
in Hamas and the Palestinian the
Liberation Organization office you
closed and the POA shredding the Iran
deal which was a threat to the United
States as well of our allies the Gulf
Arab states and the Israelis - I mean
honestly we have four Democrats running
for president Elizabeth Warren Julian
Castro Bernie Sanders Kamala Harris none
of them will speak at APEC which is a
moderate left-of-center organization
that supports Israel
that's how hardcore the Democrats have
become anti-israel and when they have an
anti-semite among them they can even
pass a resolution specifically
condemning the anti-semite by name and
yet the number three Democrat in the
House of Representatives yet again in
that party compared the President of the
United States to Adolf Hitler this is a
sick party these are sick people running
for president in the United States
there's no other explanation for this
mark levin we've missed you for three
months please come back a little more
regularly we amazing commentary tonight
thank you for that don't forget Mark
show Life Liberty to live in Sunday
night 10:00 Eastern number one show on
Sunday nights here at Fox